good morning the things that i want to
talk about today is a brand new course
that simply learn is offering that can
help you become a digital marketing
certified associate and i'm going to
give you a sort of a a preview of some
of the content that we'll be sharing in
the course
but first of all i guess i should
introduce myself i'm greg jarbo
i'm
the video and content marketing faculty
chair at market motive which is a
company based in california that's been
around since about 2007
and was acquired earlier this year by
simply learn
and i'm also an instructor at the
rutgers business school
in their many mba programs in both
digital marketing and social media
marketing
and i'm also a faculty member
in the interactive advertising bureau's
digital uh leadership program
now i also have my own firm
i'm the president and co-founder of a
company called seopr
we are an award-winning content
marketing firm
and we've worked for a variety of
different clients and i i bring some of
that experience with me into teaching
the dmca course
many times i will share an anecdote or
an example
of work that we've done to illustrate a
particular point
i'm also the author of uh a book
called youtube and video marketing in
our day that's uh some of the content
that i'm going to share with you today
uh to give you an idea of the kinds of
things that you'll learn about
youtube
in this particular course i uh write for
several weeks
and i write about uh two blog posts a
week and i've been doing that now for
well over 12 years so that that gives me
about 1200 different blog posts
if you are interested in doing a google
search you'll find that i've written
about a wide variety of topics over
the last several years
and i'm a frequent speaker at industry
conferences and
mostly in uh north america in the united
states and canada but also uh the united
kingdom
and um i've spoken at other uh
conferences uh around the world
and i'm featured in a
book that michael miller wrote called
online marketing heroes he interviewed
25 successful online marketing gurus i
was one of them
um and so that's what i bring to the
table hopefully some experience
a wide number of case studies that
either i and my firm have been working
on or
other people in the industry have
provided and i've interviewed them and
written their stories for a variety of
places
but that brings me to why you're here
we're going to be offering a new course
on digital marketing
and part of the reason we're doing this
is because the digital economy is
growing incredibly rapidly
last year in 2014
about 40 percent of the world's
population
has uh now has access to the internet
and that's up from just 16
10 years ago
so the the penetration of uh
particularly using wi-fi devices in
india
uh has increased
uh the number of people who have access
to the internet
people are now spending more than six
hours
a day online
uh either at work or
pursuing their own interests
and we now spend more time online with
online media
than we do offline either watching a
television listening to the radio
reading newspapers or magazines so the
world is shifting
and business recognizes this and they're
shifting more and more of their
operations online as well e-commerce is
growing
um the two largest markets happen to be
china and the united states but it turns
out india
is the
third largest market it is growing uh
more rapidly the the largest amount of
growth last year in new internet users
came from india
and so uh it's rapidly uh
moving into that top tier
which makes india a particularly
interesting market
for a lot of different people including
for example
uh facebook and youtube i wrote an
article um in the real seo blog
uh just a week or two ago
uh talking about how india has now
become
youtube's second largest market
and that's because uh the us is still
its largest market
uh youtube is blocked
in china as is facebook
and so it turns out with the rapid
growth of
access to the internet in india india is
now
youtube's second largest market and that
makes it uh a particularly interesting
one business is spending more money
online businesses planning to spend more
money online
so what does that mean to you well this
means that digital marketing is not just
a growing field more and more companies
have got digital marketing budgets
those budgets are increasing
at a fairly steep rate
this year according to the gartner group
digital marketing budgets
are likely to increase 17 percent
and the consequence of that is that more
and more companies
are adding more and more jobs
in the digital marketing space so in the
united states uh there is a job site
called indeed
and if you look at it you'll see over
220 000
digital marketing jobs
basically saying
we're we're trying to hire people with
this kind of background
in india there is also a job website uh
called now cree
and you'll find over 66 000 digital
marketing jobs on that website so again
the jobs are there and what's
interesting is that uh indeed did a
salary data report and discovered that
the jobs in digital marketing pay on
average
82 more
than uh traditional marketing jobs so
this is not only a rapidly growing area
it uh it pays well
so we've structured this course to help
you prepare for that kind of job
uh we'll we'll give you uh an overview
of where digital marketing fits
uh in the overall marketing mix
uh we provide uh about 27 hours worth of
detailed instruction on topics like
search engine optimization
social media marketing pay-per-click
advertising
uh web analytics content marketing email
marketing we we cover a wide variety of
uh disciplines
within digital marketing
and then we will focus on four projects
these projects are centered around uh
key tools that we think
every digital marketer will want to
understand one of them is google
analytics
which is uh the way most people
uh
basically understand how
the traffic to their website
what it did uh you know how much they
got
what people um
uh went on to let's say purchase a
product or filled out a lead generation
form
another tool that we're going to focus
on is google adwords this is the
world's most popular pay-per-click
advertising
platform
uh and we will
talk about it and
basically teach you uh how to use it
effectively
we will also set up a facebook page as
one of the projects
uh in in this course uh for a business
uh we will do a similar thing for a
youtube channel
uh for a business
and those are the four projects that we
will take you through
and some of your own time is going to be
involved in
setting things up and
getting things ready to go to market
with a uh venture that you basically get
to create yourself you
you you tell us um what business it is
that you're going to create and you um
will create a wordpress blog and a
facebook page and a youtube channel
and um and and show us that you're
you're ready you've got some hands-on uh
experience um basically adding uh web
analytics
uh to that site uh getting ready to
launch an ad campaign
that's almost
most of the course but we come back and
we'll finish
the last session that we
we go through we'll talk about digital
marketing strategy
and also
managing a digital marketing campaign
everything from from measurement to
management
so
all of that is included in the course
but i want to give you a sample that's i
think why why we're here
um give you sort of a
you know taste of the kind of
information that you'll learn
and the information i'm sharing
today
is uh some of the content that we're
going to be covering on youtube
and the interesting thing about youtube
is is that many marketers
have been there themselves to watch
videos
but they're not entirely clear on what
the best practices are for using youtube
for their own marketing purposes so
i'm going to quickly show you four free
tools
that you can use to make videos i'll
talk to you quickly about the
step-by-step process for setting up a
youtube channel for a
business which is by the way free it
doesn't cost anything to do that it does
take a little your time but it doesn't
you don't have to pay a fee to set up a
youtube channel uh we'll talk about uh
what it will take to launch let's say an
advertising campaign
on youtube using their true view ad
platform
and then i'll talk
about some different ways that you
measure results
in in this new medium
so it it turns out if you download the
youtube app which is free
it not only lets you you watch videos or
share videos with people you know
but it also has a feature that lets you
record
video you can edit it with the app
you can add filters and music
all inside the app and then you can
upload that video to youtube so again
getting started
is
incredibly simple it's also free
if you've never edited a video before
that sometimes sounds daunting
it's not
it's a question of saying okay
i've just shot something here
where do i want to start where do i want
to end do i want to use
the sound that i recorded
when i shot this
do i want to add a soundtrack
all of which can be done from the app
if you're interested in a more powerful
product there's another one out there
called the youtube video editor
it is also
free
and
you basically can use it to
create new videos if you want or it can
take existing videos you already have
allow
trim them or clip them if you decide you
want to
cut off that boring beginning or that
anti-climactic ending you can edit your
videos
you can also add music from a library of
approved
soundtracks there's a number of special
effects that you can do
use and and again you can publish it to
youtube with one click
and that's that free option
now if you're more ambitious if one of
the things that you would like to do
is
create something that tells a story
then there is another free app it's
called director
and what i like about director is it
comes with storyboards
um basically uh outlines
uh that tell you if if for example
you're trying to create a how-to
tutorial
here's some ideas for the scenes that
you might want to shoot
uh here's uh when you might want to uh
interview the expert here's when you
might want to show the product
here's how you
might want to edit that
finally
if you're going to add a narrator's
voice
do that here
if you're going to move scenes around as
you're editing it here's how you do that
and finally you you can save all your
fitted uh footage
this tool is incredibly powerful you can
tell a wide variety of stories
there are hundreds of storyboards there
to guide you through um
creating a wide range of different
genres
and again the app is free and it was
such a popular one youtube decided to
acquire the company and that's one of
the reasons why they can afford to give
this away for free
that's their business model
and then um youtube took a version of
director
and uh it also makes it available for
free
as what is called the video ad builder
so if you've never created a 40 second
ad for your on for your business
video ad builder will give you some very
simple
storyboards
so you can introduce your business
in the first 10 seconds this is just an
example of that kind of storyboard
you know
basically state your name
talk about your business
um and then in the next 20 seconds
share your enthusiasm for your business
what is it you do that you love the most
what do people
who do business with you
seem to appreciate the most um
what makes your business different than
some others and then close with a call
to action
let people know that if they're
interested in getting more information
about you where they can find that
online
or
where your shop is located so again
building a video ad
is
pretty straightforward if you download
the free app
follow the instructions
uh use the storyboard to even structure
your first
first ad so again
um a lot of tools are available
they don't cost anything
and
if you want to create a channel a
youtube channel for your business
we've helped a variety of companies do
that one of the companies that we helped
recently was thompson reuters so we've
worked for large companies as well as
smaller ones
and creating a channel is free
and
getting started is
you know
can take about 15 minutes
where uh some additional time might go
however
is if you want to then take and
customize your channel so it doesn't
look like every other
channel out there
and it turns out youtube allows you to
do a lot of customization
again at no cost
in in the sense that youtube is not
charging uh any money for this although
it can take some time and talent
um uh to pull all this together and
again we'll walk you through this
but basically you can create a channel
art
as
that you can upload
it will look good on both desktop
devices as well as mobile
devices
and it can then give your channel a very
unique look and feel
and that's part of what will set you
apart
you can design a channel icon
and this is uh it could be as simple as
your logo or it can be a small
uh image that you create that lets
people know um
you know
when they see
your content around youtube that it's
from you
one of the things that makes the youtube
channel very powerful is it gives you
the option of
if someone is coming to your channel for
the first time
you can show them what is called a
channel trailer this is like a movie
trailer this is your your preview your
highlight your introduction the first
video you want people to see if they
then go on and subscribe to your channel
then obviously when they come back
they're no longer a first time viewer so
you get to show them something different
that's a what to watch next module
to people who have been to your channel
before and what you can basically inform
them of is i've got a new video you
might want to check that out or i've got
one of my most popular videos i'd like
you to see that now
you can basically suggest visitors to
your channel what to watch next
there are some other tools that will
allow you to create sections and
playlists
all of these tools are for free very
very powerful
uh channel management um features
and it doesn't cost you anything you
just need to learn how to use them
and then if you decide you know i'm
ready to start thinking about
advertising
on youtube um
up until uh about september of this year
um i would have to take you down a
special kind of
area that would teach you how to create
youtube ads
it was a separate art to itself
which is explains why
not as people not as many people
understand how to do this well it turns
out as of september of this year
youtube
and uh its video platform have been
totally integrated
within the google adwords
platform which is the most popular one
in the world
and now if you want to create a video
campaign
it's as easy and you're using the same
platform the same tools as you might if
you were going to create a search ad or
a display ad
now all you do is basically say okay i
want to create a video campaign
and it's now just a type of ad format
totally integrated within the adwords
tool
now
even though it has been integrated it
turns out
youtube's trueview ads have some unique
features
that
give video some additional power that
you won't find in let's say a display ad
or a
text ad
in search
one of the things that trueview does
is it gives you this option called the
in-stream video ads
and what will happen with an in-stream
ad is somebody will
want to come see a video it could be
i want to watch youtube rewind which is
the highlights of the year but before
youtube rewind starts
an ad will appear
and the first five seconds of the ad
will begin playing and then a little
button will come up to say what you'd
like to skip add
that gives the user the ability to say i
don't want to watch an ad i want to go
straight and watch youtube rewind and
that's fine
if somebody hits the skip ad button the
advertiser pays nothing
but if the person does not hit the skip
ad button and they watch your ad for
longer than 30 seconds
or if your ad happens to be particularly
short let's say your ad is only a 15
second ad then for the duration of the
ad
or until they begin interacting with you
and your ad let's say they they click on
uh something in your ad a
a link that will take them to your
webpage if somebody interacts with your
ad then and only then
are you charged that's why it's called
true view
um
basically you're only advertising to
people who have chosen to watch your
advertising it is not intrusive
it is incredibly popular it's incredibly
powerful
but it has this feature that basically
allows the users to skip the ad if
they're not interested
and there's also a version of this it's
sister or it's brother if you will
called the in-display video ad this
doesn't appear before a video runs
it appears to the side of the video
generally over
the area where related videos normally
appear
and what is very typical in youtube in a
session
is i'm going to watch one video when
that video is over i'll look off to the
right
to see what other related videos i might
want to watch next and there's your ad
and again you don't pay anything for it
unless somebody clicks
to watch the ad
now that then begs the question okay if
somebody watches
so what what does that do for your
business
and it turns out youtube
has wrestled with that issue as well and
come back with an incredibly
innovative solution one of the solutions
i'm going to share with you is called
brand lift
and what youtube will do for an
advertiser
for free
this doesn't cost any additional money
it's if you are running an ad campaign
in youtube
and you decide i'd really like to know
whether i'm having any impact on
increasing brand awareness
youtube will take a sample
of the target audience that you've
selected so i want to get let's say
outdoor enthusiasts those are the people
i want to
show my
video to about the business that i have
that provides white water rafting
trips
near one of the national parks in the
united states
so i only want to reach people who are
into um white water rafting that's a
it's not everybody
in the country it's people who enjoy
that kind of outdoor sport
well
okay
then
you
basically target that group of people
and what trueview enables you to do is
to take a sample a small subset
of that target audience that you want to
run your ad against and it won't show
your ad to that group
in other words they are the holdback
group
they don't see your ad
most of the rest of the audience that
you've targeted does see your ad
but 48 hours two days after your
campaign launches
youtube sends out
basically a survey
to both groups people who saw your ad
people who didn't see your ad
they asked a couple of quick questions
about brand awareness about brand
preference
about ad recall and
then
basically give you the comparison
people who didn't see your ad
you know
have this kind of brand awareness of you
people who have just seen your ad
have a different degree and what what
basically a number of surveys
that
have been done using this free tool have
come back is the average company
sees about a 17 point
lift in brand awareness
because they've
run their ads on youtube so again you
now get a measurement
a metric
uh that you can use to say did we
improve brand awareness yeah and i can
measure it and it's scientifically valid
it's
i'm not guessing i'm not making
estimates i'm not calculating the number
of impressions i might have had
and making some assumptions i've got
now to demonstrate brand lift
you also can
create hard data using website traffic
in the early days of youtube people
would watch the video
and then maybe a day later or a week
later might actually go over and visit
the client's website but you couldn't
connect those dots it was
hard to show that
people watching a video had then come to
visit your website
now it's much simpler now what youtube
is offering is a technology it calls
cards c-a-r-d-s
cards sort of like a deck of cards
and what that is is basically a link
that can appear on the video that people
can click on and go to a variety of
places
including your website
so you can now drive traffic
from a video straight to a landing page
on your website where you may have
products for sale or
whatever it is that you're you're trying
to do so driving traffic is now
not only measurable it always was
measurable but it is now simple
for the user to take advantage of it's
not
obscurely hidden away somewhere down in
the description
so that is a game changer and then when
you get to your website one of the
things that
google has done
is make it a lot easier to track what
are called conversions
not just i got a visitor to my website
they came they looked they wandered
around they went away i have no idea
what they did
uh now you can actually begin to say
okay how many people who came to my
website from any number of places
including youtube
went on to
you know download a white paper
subscribe to a newsletter
fill in a lead generation form
do some on-site e-commerce download an
app make a phone call any number of
different kinds of quote conversions
and that again is a game changer because
now you're not just measuring traffic
you're
beginning to measure
frankly business
and that makes it incredibly more
valuable
and that also enables you to then begin
calculating the return on marketing
investment
this is one of those things that people
have been wrestling
with for about 20 years how do you
calculate this well it turns out
there's a formula for calculating it
we will go through that in this course
and by the way if you can now measure
not just the traffic that you're
generating but the conversions that
you're generating you can begin
calculating uh the revenue that a
particular campaign
is producing and you can then look at
the cost of creating that campaign
and doing um basically the calculation
to say okay
this was a profitable campaign
it didn't just build brand awareness
it generated
traffic it generated leads it generated
sales it generated revenue and it did
all of that cost effectively we made
money
on this campaign
now
before we uh end uh i want to give you
uh one
bit of advice we're going to try to
train you
and get you prepared to not only take a
certification exam
but also to turn in four different
projects that demonstrate that you've
learned all of this
but you're at the beginning of a very
long journey i think it's a really
rewarding one i think it could be an
entire career
but
one of the
false assumptions i i just want to deal
with up front is
quote you can't learn all in 48 hours
and never have to learn anything ever
again
this is a rapidly rapidly changing field
to give you an illustration of that i
just wanted to show you this data point
when i started writing the first book on
youtube back in 2008
there were about 15 hours of new video
content uploaded every
minute to youtube
which meant i couldn't watch it all
there was no way um you know but nobody
could watch it all
uh and so people
had a variety of ways of finding the
kind of content that interested them
well that was 2008
this year in 2015 seven years later
400 hours of new video content
is being uploaded to youtube
every
minute
and this means that as you are learning
how to be more adept at youtube
marketing or any part of the digital
marketing mix
so are a lot of other people you have a
lot of competition
it raises
the stakes in the game
it means you uh have never learned
enough you always need to learn more
things change
and
you know you need to change along with
them so
you will begin this journey we will help
you get started in this field we will
give you
the foundation
as long as you understand that it's not
over at that point
you're in a very fast changing
fast growing business
that will require you to stay up to date
and
basically it's a fun industry to be in
but it's not a slow moving one
and i want to uh conclude this with a
story of a small company
that took youtube marketing
and uh helped turn its little business
into a multi-million dollar business in
a short period of time
the name of this company is aurabrush
o-r-a-b-r-u-s-h
and they were founded by a gentleman
named dr bob
wagstaff
who had invented a tongue cleaner
that's right
who knew that you could clean your
tongue i mean there are toothbrushes
people understand that
there is a mouthwash people understand
that this was something different this
is a
tongue cleaner and the reason he created
this is it turns out most of the germs
come from your tongue
and those are the germs that give people
bad breath so if you want to cure bad
breath
you need to clean your tongue and that's
that's not something everyone does yet
they haven't gotten into that habit it's
a whole different kind of idea
and he found that nobody wanted his
product he would try to get
retail stores to put it on their shelf
they didn't want to put it on their
shelf
he tried to sell the patent to this
invention
to
some of the big companies out there they
didn't want to buy his patent
at one point he even um bought a
television time
created an infomercial
and tried to sell his product direct on
tv and he ended up spending about forty
thousand dollars buying the television
time
and he only sold um a small number
of his products and each product only
cost about seven dollars
so he lost a lot of money it wasn't
working
so he went to a marketing course
at the university near him in utah
brigham young university
and he basically said uh is there anyone
here who can help me
and there was a student in the back of
the room jeffrey harmon
who basically said well have you heard
of youtube
and he said no i haven't uh and jeffrey
said well it could help you and he's and
so dr bob basically said look jeffrey
i've noticed that you've come to school
today on a bicycle but you're in your
20s
i'm 76 years old i have a vintage
motorcycle which i can't write anymore
i'll make you a deal i will trade you my
motorcycle if you'll put together a
marketing plan
on how i can use this youtube to sell
aurabrush
and
jeffrey did the deal
jeffrey said fine and he got a friend of
his
to
sort of uh act in the video he got
another friend of his to write a script
for the video it cost five hundred
dollars to create the video three
hundred dollars went to the scriptwriter
the other two hundred dollars was for uh
like equipment and things like that
but it cost them five hundred dollars
but they created this video a very funny
video
called the bad breath test how to tell
when your breath stinks
and uh if you look down underneath
you'll see that it has almost
million
views
and what is more significant is it
helped orabrush sell
one
million
of its aurabrush tongue cleaners at
seven dollars each
so again a 500
bit of marketing
helped the company make seven
million dollars in revenue and it put
the company on the map
using video
and they didn't stop there
this would be a great story all by
itself but they didn't stop there
they also decided that it would be a lot
more effective if they could get
retail shelf space
and the biggest retailer in the united
states is a company called walmart
they've got 3 500 stores right across
the country and so aurabrush did
something also pretty amazing
they created a video for one person
it's called an unlisted video you can't
watch this video unless you are sent
the
url to the video
if you get the url to the video and it's
right there at the bottom of the slide
then you can watch it and only then can
you watch it you won't find this in
search you won't find it if you go to
their channel it's unlisted
but in this unlisted video aurabrush
basically told the buyer at walmart
here's why you should stock our product
on your shelves
in all 3500
of your stores
and what orabrush was hoping for
is that the buyer would say okay let's
let's have a meeting why don't you come
into
arkansas here uh where we're
headquartered and we'll talk about this
and we'll have a meeting
well it turned out there was no meeting
or orabrush didn't get that call what
they got instead
was an order for uh several hundred
thousand seven hundred and thirty five
thousand
aura brushes
and oh by the way can you distribute
them to our 3500 stores
and oh by the way can you do that in
about a month
and so all of a sudden a video created
for one person but the right person
engaged that person generated the order
and so even without getting millions and
millions of views you can see this this
video now has 56 000 views
why because it's been used as a case
study and a lot of courses that i've
been teaching so i've been sharing this
with a lot of people i
i shared the unlisted
basically url there with you
but uh what this basically uh you know
a video for one person
uh basically got orabrush into walmart
and then something really funny started
happening
some of orabrush's customers said this
is great it's you know curing my bad
breath
but is it safe for me to use with my dog
my dog has bad breath
and the answer is no that's not an
appropriate use of this product but that
was also a signal that maybe there was a
market
for a new product that would basically
help cure dog bad breath
so dr bob went back to work he invented
a new product
and basically
it was a great concept
but nobody knew if there was actually
enough market demand for it
so how do you find out are there enough
dog owners
that would actually use this if we
brought this product to market
well orabrush tested it and they tested
it in a number of different ways
one of which is they went to indiegogo a
crowdsourcing site and said look if we
can raise forty thousand dollars in
initial orders
uh then we'll go develop this product
so um
raise your hand donate some money if we
get enough money we'll go build this
thing
well they didn't just raise forty
thousand dollars i raised sixty thousand
dollars
so they brought the product to board
and then they tested it and they tested
it and they changed the way that they
targeted
uh this product because where do you
find
people who might purchase it i mean what
what is the profile of that audience so
they had to do some experimentation they
experimented with different content
what happens if we get a third party
testimonial
does that help us
you know
improve
and by the time they were through with
their testing they'd finally found a way
not just to get people to watch the
video
but to get people who watched the video
to place enough orders so that they
could make a big profit
and so they launched the product
and within months
they
basically were able to generate
about a a video with about 4.3 million
views
that generated over 75 000 orders from
people
for this new
product that would cure bad breath and
dogs
and they made over two million dollars
selling that product literally in less
than a year
after
testing it and bringing it to market
so again
kinds of things that you will learn here
are lessons that you can apply
uh little orabrush has done it they are
now a multi-million dollar company they
have a big product line
and those are the kinds of stories that
we'll share with you
but we're going to cover a lot of other
things as well we're again we're going
to cover search engine optimization
social media marketing pay-per-click
advertising
web analytics content marketing email
marketing this is this is just today is
just a sample of the kind of content
that you'll learn
we will dig into a different tool so in
addition to youtube we're also going to
look at facebook and google analytics
and google adwords
and you're going to work on some
projects
in addition to the material that you'll
learn in the course
and we hope to get you uh ready uh for a
number of different certification exams
one of which is the online marketing
certified certified associate
the omca test
normally it costs money to just take the
test that is bundled into your
course so if you take the
dmca course through simply learn
that fee for that certification test
is is paid by simply learn
we also get you prepared for uh other
certification exams that google
or facebook or youtube uh offer
and
you know that's our goal that's what
we're trying to do we're trying to get
your job ready
it takes about oh six weeks to take the
course
there's a element of the projects that
you can turn in that can take up to
three months
that's at your pace we understand that
some of you um you know
uh are
have a day job already
uh you're trying to do this at night or
on weekends
to uh get ready for your next career
and so we we try to provide you with
that kind of flexibility
and
we really want to give you the skill
sets so you can get into the ground
level
uh although this is a rapidly growing
and changing field as i mentioned
and and so um you're you're
sort of catching the tiger by the tail
but we think it's going to be
an incredible journey we think it'll be
a great career
and that's what we're trying to prepare
you for
and
if you decide that this is the kind of
course that will help you on your way
please sign up
thank you very much for your time
i think we'll call that
call that a day